Roger I'm a big believer in
infrastructure as code all settings for
my system should be in files that are
checked into Source control yeah that
way you always know what's running in
your production environment many
developers use terraform for that right
but terraform is not right for everyone
I've heard that we can do declarative
deployments in Cloud run without
terraform by using a yaml file for our
configuration it lets us manage our
Cloud run service declaratively so
instead of making lots of manual changes
the yl file just describes what the
service should look like if you're using
terraform stick with that if not this
could do the trick if you keep that yo
file in Source control you always know
what the latest settings are for your
service and you can rerun them at any
time when things change and you deploy a
new revision of your Cloud run service
you update the yaml file in your repo
it's very clear what it's currently
running in your production environment